Statistics gives us the power to make inferences.
When we say inference.
We can mean two things.
Either making inferences about some relationship.
For example the relationship between salary and experience.
Is it the case that the more experience they
have? They can demand a higher salary the second thing
could mean.
Is forecasting for example, we can use statistics
to forecast future sales.
Or the future number of tourists in the
city.
Or how much traffic you could expect on a highway and so
everything that we are going to look at in this course we'll have
to do with how statistics helps us understand relationships
within data.
and how to make forecasts
based on
existing data and three main topics that
we are going to understand and great detail include regression
analysis hypothesis testing
and the Bayesian theorem. Now,
the reason why I have bay z and Theorem in the
second half of this
screen here is because the first two topics are
techniques within classical statistics classical
statistics or as it's also known
frequently statistics the third major topic that
we will discuss in this course.
Which is the Bayesian theorem, it's fundamentally different from how
frequently statistics works. We'll talk
about the difference between frequent statistics.
and Bayesian statistics in a separate
video the first three modules
Are dedicated to the frequentist?
statistical techniques
and the fourth module Bayesian statistics
There will also be a fifth module which will of course
Talk About Time series.